[Music]
hello everyone
i'm grand master dennis borsch and this
is
the games of the week now
we've got plenty of interesting end
games that happened this event
so i actually kind of wanted to focus on
the ones with these upcoming
superstars now there was the game
between hare krishna and donchenko
they weren't exactly the top of the
field but was a very interesting end
game and i'm
if we have exactly we might just
check that out as well but i want to
start out
first with this game between
voytacek and yesi panko let's take a
look
we are going to start off we are not
very interested in the opening
but from somewhere around here
bishop a6 a4 c6
it kind of starts from an opening
where esc panko surprises his opponent
and goes straight into
a position where white is rather rather
underdeveloped now this will be sort of
a mix
between a bit of an end game
and middle game so it's not
like per se an end game position
that would be mostly the federal game
and we're going to focus
a bit more on that one but here
c6 knight a3 takes
knight d7 actually black gets
some very very good play as white's
pieces are sort of scattered all around
the board
well in fact mostly just staying
back in the garage so in this game
between muay the second yesi penko
voitusek is struggling whenever you have
this big dilemma of what to do
you always come up with the thought of
castling would be great
however castling is not at all
an option because it will take one
two three and four moves to castle
now there is one certain magnus carlsen
who used to say
that castling is important of course but
he says
that if it takes three moves it's tough
if it takes four moves however
that's an issue
knight e2 rook b8
pressing because he knows that in
general
that is what black is trying to do
he's pressing on b2 and he is
trying to take advantage of the fact
that king on
e1 is still stuck rookie two
castles knight c3
queen a5 bishop e2 so this is
actually an important position and i
want to
ask you guys what you think would be the
best way
to continue we already know that
the king is likely to make it to the
other side of the board
however we still have the momentum as
black
what would be an interesting way of
continuing
so the big issue is of course that
white is really really behind
there is this move a rook d8 and there
is this idea of
c5 if you thought about that you
are on point and this is what esc panko
is going for
he is trying to break it open
okay now queen c2 happens
c5 so notice that yesi panko
is very good with initiative that was
actually very well known and seen
in his game versus magnus crossing which
he famously won
as i believe most of you know and here
he does
the same thing he takes control castles
c takes d4 bishop d4 knight c5
now vine managed to castle however
the pieces over there are still very
much scattered
and they're not enjoying their presence
like in the future the knight actually
is headed towards d3
and even though there's a c for pawn
weakness the knight
is going to be quite strong over there
knight b5 and here yes ivanka actually
comes up with a brilliant brilliant
idea that is sort of unbelievable
and then we sort of get into the endgame
phase
so here actually black has a beautiful
move
let's try to find it
we are going to get towards the end game
chat
so i know this is indeed not an end game
yet
for that i apologize but that's what
we're going for
so bishop takes b5 would run into ideas
such as bishop takes c5
not that it's necessarily a bad move but
it doesn't take
a big advantage of the momentum
because if bishop b5 there is this move
of bishop c5 and white is more or less
okay
with those two bishops this is fine
so it turns out that there is this
spectacular idea of rook takes d4
knight takes d4 knight b3
and this is really unheard of it seems
like
what is going on black is just losing
material
out of nowhere but it turns out not to
be the case
it turns out that this king is so
unfortunate on g1
there are these queen c5 ideas and
you will run into those normally knight
c6 would be
the bully move kind of double attacking
the queen and rook but there is this
queen c5 check
taking the knight and just
chasing that king away
so knight b3 again there's really no way
of
stopping this if you go queen c3 there
is queen c5
and this pin is the most
annoying because there's e5 black gets
the two pieces
and with passive pieces such as rook on
a2 and bishop on e2
it is black who is definitely dominating
now this this move actually honestly
shocked me when i saw it myself
i couldn't believe my eyes that this is
working but it does
knight b5 that's the only move but now
we have bishop takes b5
it takes b5 and then that rook
is a dropping bishop takes c4
and here black has the funniest of moves
you can think of but it works
and in chess if it works it really just
does work there's no questioning a good
move
so what was that funny move that yesi
banco played here
it feels like in this middle game very
close to the end game
black is in trouble but not so
really not so
black is able to do a houdini
if knight d4 there is this move of queen
c3 winning that night
so that doesn't really work as well
so believe it or not yes panko played
knight a1 with the knight on avon
getting stuck
over there and just not enjoying its
existence
but an extra piece is an extra piece
it's not you see not something you see
all the time
queen c3
queen a4 and now
naturally we tend to want to win these
knights on a1 but it turns out
not to be that useful and not that great
the big move here that voitacek i think
is understandably
missed is rook b1 which is just an
unbelievable move
the knight can't escape and b3 is coming
and this would have sort of leveled the
game
but for someone to find rook b1 you have
to be a magician
or at least mihal tal this is not
something you can do
b3 is the human reaction but that sort
of gets into
the end game that we wanted to talk
about queen takes b3
it takes b3 rook takes b5
and here we have to decide in what way
we are going to play black definitely of
course has the extra pawn
but that is not a guarantee you're going
to win it
so our opponent has a white squared
bishop
and that sort of begs the question
how should black continue on
where should black put his pieces
and just a disclaimer here white did
play rook c1
obviously we can't capture because we
would get back ranked
so here we have to decide where to put
our pawns
and with that how to continue and devise
a plan
dark squares so what would be the ideal
formation for black
first instinct move the king okay both
both of them make sense
bringing in the king makes a lot of
sense and also putting pawns on the dark
squares makes sense especially with this
bishop
on the other kind of color
rook b8 does feel a little bit passive
and i would avoid that if
if it's not necessary
so here actually yesipanko played g5 so
if you had the idea
of putting a pawn on the dark squares
you were correct
there are all those squares
under control which is very very
important
grab some space and also there is
some hope of rotating the knight around
with knight d7 knight
e5 sort of consolidating
rook c3 king g7 notice that yesipanko is
in no hurry
he is up a pawn he has a great position
but he doesn't want to show his ideas
just yet he doesn't want to commit
with pushing that a pawn because the
more you push that pawn
the easier target it may become king f2
so once we decided to put some paws on
dark squares
what would be our second plan we already
had and already decided to put a pawn on
g5
but what would be another way of
continuing
the past pawn really can't go that's a
good point exquisite
although it is there is some potential
with that pawn
i guess we need idea to have weaknesses
on both sides that is correct so
just having an extra pawn probably an
extra pawn
should still be winning but the more
weaknesses you get
in your opponent's camp the more likely
you're going to win
yes so simply push the pawn
up to h5 and h4
h6 is flexible however it's not as
energetic
as pushing it up to this square what
could be the point of getting that pawn
to h4
well the point is to fix those pawns
and potentially create an extra target
i mean h6 makes sense but probably isn't
just
not as aggressive and yes panko is more
of like this
karpov school of chess solid
yet classically aggressive
king e3 h4 fixing
those pawns and putting them on dark
squares
so this bishop can never reach it
so a we put our pawns on dark squares
b our king is safe it's surrounded by
all those pawns and knights so there's
no real way of coming close to it
so here comes question number two
what would be the ideal spot for this
knot
for this for this knot on f6 that is
how about g4 g4 makes sense but that
might be committing your ideas a little
bit early
reroute the knight yep that's a great
idea the question is just
where ragnorak
it definitely could go to e5 is there
any apple any other apples that we can
go to
so this is one way of getting there of
course there are
some problems
but that's not necessarily
you know it's still an idea even if it
doesn't work right now
f4 yes so there are a couple of plans
that black can do one of them
is to get this knight to e5 and the
other one is to go to f4
and honestly i kind of prefer f4 because
it directly
presses down the g2 pawn and you can
also reroute it
if they chase you away with knight g6
and knight e5
now definitely you can go for the knight
g8 97
this plan it just takes a bit more time
this is just two moves and the quicker
you can get to your destination the
better
g3 sort of anticipating that maneuver
and again he goes h3 and these are those
little moves
that have so much sting to them of
course this can become a weakness
but it does fix that h2 pawn
which will become a target bishop d1
sort of going that direction but now he
goes rogue b2
and now you can see the hidden idea of
pushing this h
pawn all up to h3 it's sort of
fixed there and now you have a great
position
not just the a pawn but the h-pawn
so you've got those two weaknesses on
the
one side and the other side and that
should be enough for a win
bishop e2 g4
and g4 makes a lot of sense he is
actually trying to break through the
last barricade
and if he can get close to that pawn
you're just winning
f takes knight takes c4 of course you
can't take because check here and rook
h2
rook a3 knight g5
rook takes check and suddenly
we did lose that pawn on this side of
the board
but there are just too many weaknesses
on the king's side
and that's enough for yesipanko to mop
up the game
because king d4 rook b1 going over there
and picking up the h2 pawn
and with white's pieces all scattered
around the board
this is just losing king e3 here
rook a5 king f6 over defending
again notice that everything
that yesi panko does is solid
everything's defended that rook is
undefended that is true but there's
really no way you can
attack it right now bishop f3 takes
rook a1 rook b2 and it might seem
premature to
resign here but really there's not much
white can do this is just completely
losing
so this was the first game i wanted to
show from
esi penko versus voitasec
the second game we are going to
start from the middle
so let's start from
here this position bishop e7
this game is between alireza
versus anton giharo david a very typical
position not saying that anyone is
really better here
but probably it's just easier to play
with white
so we're going to watch and see how fire
ruja slowly but surely outplays
his young arrival
queen b6 rook b1
so he played king f1 queen b6 rogue b1
queen b5 takes takes
so black gets an end game
but it comes at a cost the cost of those
two pawns being doubled
and potentially very weak now
in end games the value of weaknesses
sort of rise and if you can fix them
you should so here actually
firouza's next move is very very
important and that one is a3
he controls that square so there's no b
forever coming close
and with that this will become an
a chronic weakness that black
will have to deal with not that white
can attack it right now
but end games are all about long-term
targets and that b5 pawn is one
h5 just fixing this side of the board
not letting ferruja go h4h5
but of course he couldn't go h5 now
because of b4
a3 h5 and that kind of makes
some non-forcing positions forcing
so a3 was logical and he just
was a tempo short of expanding on the
other side
knight b3 so one of the big questions is
where is this not really going to and if
you
are familiar with some of these reversed
calls bad structures you'd know where
this knight is headed
yeah i mean these super talented kids
already know how to deal and play these
lines
they know that if they have a weakness
they need
to put pressure on them so the idea of
knight b3 is not
really to go to b3 it is a start of a
maneuver
getting this knight towards d3
and if you can get the knight to d3
it'll be super useful
f6 but it first goes to rookie one
pressing that pawn on e6 making sure
there are no breaks
because there's just too many white
pieces guarding the old important e5
square
and now he goes for this maneuver of
knight c1 knight d3
king f1 knight c1 very purposeful play
by alireza
and this is actually one of those things
that sort of distinguishes them
from the other ground masters they're
very purposeful
and they are bent on following through
with their plans
knight f8 knight d3
so the thing what you see right now is
maneuvering from both sides
but it does seem that first is a little
bit more successful
now f6 is not necessarily bad here it's
not
the best you don't want to play f6 if
you don't have to
but it does control the e5 square and if
anton giharo david
could get e5 in he would be more or less
okay
but he's never going to get it
and g6 bishop g3
knight a5 so
whenever you look at these positions you
always wonder
okay i've got a knight on d3 that's
great
we've got our bishop over there right
over here
these are all great things we've got the
rook on the open file
but chess is about things that don't
work
and in this position there are a couple
of things that
don't work that king on f1 is just not
ideal
and furuja sort of realizes well then
let's improve it so he goes on
for a small walk towards h2
knight c4 rook e2
rookie 8 king h2
so ferruja was brave enough to take his
time to get there
get to h2 and involve this rook on h1
so he actually not just improved the
king that was sort of in the way in f1
but he also improves this rook on h1
and puts even more pressure on this
square
not to mention the e6 square
bishop f8 rookie one but again you might
be asking
so what what what happened what is the
difference
no big difference just yet
but first is getting more and more of a
grip
on what's happening
b6 king g1
b6 is a nice defensive move by the way
on by anton guiharro
he's just making sure there is no knight
c5
but does that change the dynamic of the
game
not really it's still the same dynamic
white is
in cruise control owning that square
and just having a better position
in fact notice that this knight that
moved from d
to c1 to d3 is actually over defending
the b2 pawn
shouldn't black trade the dark squared
bishop it's actually not a bad idea
probably is something that anton giharo
should have considered
because if you have less space
exchanging just
make a lot of sense
white does have infinite time rook a8
bishop f4 rook c8
and when i was younger i also thought
that you have the luxury of just moving
back and forth back and forth but it
really turns out that
it's not going to help you by the way
black couldn't take on f4
because then fee rujov would have
threats
on h5 and e6 that's just not worth
it now it's not that waiting is
necessarily a
bad way of playing chess but it doesn't
improve your position
and if your opponent finds a plan that
will be just very
detrimental g3
so for the moment it's kind of clear we
don't have a way to break through
on the queen side neither for black
neither
for white even though we'd love to win
that b-pawn
so the only way we could play is on the
king's side
rook c6 king g2 sort of
preparing some maneuvering and maybe
potential f3g for ideas
bishop e7 knight g1
so he's trying to get this knight to h3
out of the way so you can start
promoting and pushing those pawns
why move the king from age two
well one of the things could be to avoid
exchanging the bishop
but i don't think that was the main idea
the main idea really was
just to maneuver around as black really
doesn't have anything to do
and just get the knight over there
knight g1 bishop f8 knight
h3 bishop e7
knight g1 bishop f8
knight f3 and you might be asking
rightfully so what are these moves like
why is alireza just repeating
well they're on move 33 and this was an
over the board
tournament so they were in no rush
of showing their intentions also
the closer they get to move 40 the more
likely they're going to be
playing this position with more time so
i guess alireza didn't
feel like actually show his hands early
on he's just kind of
maneuvering and waiting
bishop seven and now he goes king h3
just making 100
sure that is no repetition
rk8 bishop c1
moving the bishop away potentially
setting up knight f4 ideas
we're thinking of bishop c1 once the
king gets there
yeah so knight f4 is a potential idea
but the best part here
for white is that you
are still not showing your intentions
um and for black to sort of expect your
move
that's kind of difficult but again
inside
2020 rook h8
would make a lot of sense sort of
discouraging
alireza from opening up the position
now you do not want to sacrifice a pawn
because that just gives yourself too
many problems
i think a better way of defending is to
stay passive
but sort of discouraging and that's why
i kind of find rookie shade a better
idea here
antongiharo david could definitely sort
of just
press and push alireza away
it's not that it necessarily stops the
idea as alireza can prepare it with rook
g1 and g4
but you may as well try
if you really don't have like a direct
say and that's kind of the problem of
these positions
you don't have a direct say of
what white is going to do you're just
there waiting
which is very uncomfortable segment
rookie 8
sort of anticipating pressure on the
e-pawn
but now alireza goes for g4 and that
might have
came as a surprise take sticks
now he goes rook h8
h5 so he's claiming a little bit more of
space
i mean you are putting some
psychological pressure on your opponent
it's not that necessarily your position
is winning or even better
but the fact that they have to find some
moves
make it difficult h5
knight f8 knight f4 and suddenly
alireza went all in with the attack
and black is completely tied up this
rook cannot move anymore
it has a business to tend to there's
lots of pressure on e6
not to mention the fact that there is
this
beautiful idea of knight takes d5 nef
takes rook takes e7
and white is just much better
bishop d8 but all of these young
kids and prodigies they're very well
aware of
tactics so mostly the way
they were out played over at playing
each other was
positional play and that's what alireza
does in this game
so already alireza put a lot of pressure
on
but it's still not yet winning he is of
course dominating
but there is some work to be done so
goes rook h1
over defending the h pawn but like
he isn't threatening anything specific
yet
just consolidating rook g8
not h4 and this is again
i mentioned earlier on that yesi panko
is more of like the player
who likes sort of being
restrictive and solid but in this game
firuja
actually does the same thing he isn't
really going for like a straight up plan
he is just taken away and restricting
whatever
anton giharo is trying to do anton
giharo wanted to play g5
he made sure that there is 90 h4 and you
have a firm control over that square
bishop c7 trying to exchange
but firuja goes no no no no no
no exchange for you knight d7
rookie one and this is
something that used to be called
anaconda chess
you are slowly taking away the
way of playing exactly like a ball
constrictor
very much in the style of galakomsky
agata kamski
also naturally tended to like playing
this way he's not showing his attentions
but he's slowly slowly taking away all
the play and oxygen from his opponent's
plans
again like it's very difficult to move
and you never know as a defender whether
you should lash
out or just sit and wait but the more
you sit and wait
the stronger the grip gets by alireza
rookie 8 and before we talked about the
idea of exchanging the bishops
and we felt that it's good for black but
guess what it's actually alireza who
gives and sort of offers the trade of
bishops
bishop takes knight takes f4
but the fight still revolves around who
gets to play e5
or if black will get to play e5 at
all so after takes knight takes
again you don't have this idea of e5
because in that scenario the d5 falls
and you lose the
so rook d6 king h3
again no rush and sort of anticipates
ideas such as the knight e5
later on
knight f8 knife g6 knight f
g6
pressing on that knight potentially
threatening that e6 square and f4 f5 is
incoming
and with these rooks sort of
discoordinated
f4 e5 f4 f5 that is
very very annoying and is very close to
just winning straight up
and h7 f4 and it's coming closer
rook dd8 and again anton gihado seems to
be
trouble never quite
there never just in time
he seems to be okay but again there pops
in a new problem
so goes rook g1 knight d6
and this is the moment it seems that hey
he is going to get to e4
and then you're sort of struggling
as white because once you kind of cover
the e6
pawn weakness that not only e4 might
just become too powerful however
now firujra does the old switcheroo
and i'm going to ask you dear viewers
tell me
what is the old switcheroo that alireza
is hoping for in this position
we've been attacking the e6 pawn for
like the past
20 25 moves but now we're going to
change our minds
yep you should go after the g pawn
rook eg2
you're going after the g pawn but it
seems like
okay like you go after the g pawn what's
the big deal
rook g8
but when it comes to spectacular
solutions
alireza knows when when to and how to do
them
the next move is going to be the game
changer
can you spot the game changer move
yeah indeed chad is saying there's just
not enough space over for
black to defend in fact if not for this
move
it would have been actually possibly
tenable
for black but this move just destroys
black's defenses
yeah knight h8 is definitely an idea
but in that case there is king f8
and still can still black can hold on
barely but can still hold on
but you are looking in the right
direction
not age it just doesn't work it is a
pretty cool move
but if you find knight h8 finding the
other move will be a piece of cake
yep knight e7 and this is a brilliant
move
again that h7 knight is just
awful and the king takes the g7
and that's the issue that you're facing
if king takes there is this move
takes takes and you can pick up that
knight on h7 with a winning position
and you just take it actually you check
first
and then you take it with a completely
dominating position
which is just technically winning for
firoja
but if they don't take that's not really
an option because if you move the rook
then you just take here and like you
sleep
the board takes and rook g8 is just
checkmates
so knight e7 looked like an idea
that uh looks like just a cheapo but
it's a deadly cheapo at that
so knight e7 here anton giharo tries
knight g5 which is the last try but
already it's collapsing
takes king takes takes takes
check king f7
now he realizes that he has a lot of
pressure on the g
pawn and
knight f3 and knight e5 will be the
decisive moment
and how can we tell that white is just
completely winning
well black has plenty of weaknesses
on g7 e6 b6 and b5
those are four weaknesses that's a lot
of weaknesses
not to mention that white species are
just
miles and miles away better than blacks
pieces on d8 and g8 not to mention that
this king on f7
is just in the way talking about being
in the way there's knight f3
knight to e5 is coming knight g5 is a
threat
and there's just too many threats to
handle and this is just winning
exactly the difference between a cheapo
and winning is
whether there's an escape square yeah
but here there was
no escape squares for anton giharo
rook f8 rook the f8
knight e5 check king is seven takes
takes
takes king f6
h6 rook h8
king g4 takes and when it seems like
things are
under control it turns out it's not
under control really
because the king is in deep trouble here
uh one is anton guiharo david
resigned but if he would have moved the
knight
there's rook f7 checkmate and that goes
to show
that alireza going from a tactical
player
he is sort of developing his uh
positional chops
and he's getting closer and closer to
becoming a universal player that we
didn't expect
him like a couple of years ago to see
and
this position was maybe slightly better
for him but not at all winning
but like a ball constrictor slowly
slowly slowly
he'd take away all the oxygen from anton
giharo's position
and he managed to outplay his opponent
so this was i think a very very
interesting game but i do want to take
a quick look at the other game between
hari krishna and donchenko
and for that i do want to take a look
from a specific position
starting over
here this position
so rook d8
was played by donchenko and we get this
type of position
which seems so cut and dry yet
it's so lively why is it so lively well
it has to do with all of these pawn
weaknesses
on d6 b6 and b7
and the same pawn weaknesses for
white excuse me but
apart from that this bishop on c8 is
just too passive
and oftentimes you're struggling to get
that bishop out
because of queen takes d6 and this
bishop is just stronger in general
so here white goes a4 stopping any
rookie for ideas
attacking the c4 pawn so what
really is going wrong in this position
for black
is the lack of space and the
piece passivity and they're just too
passive they can't hold the position
together that well
rook a5 rogue b1 bishop d7
this is a typical g3 nimzo in fact
popularized by kasparov himself
now i'm not saying that white is better
in fact objectively
this is an even or balanced position
but you'll see that there are some
tricks and ideas
that black should have considered
rook b4 bishop c6
solving this issue that we mentioned
earlier on queen d4
takes takes rook c5
so black is actually consolidating
however his pieces are still rather
passive
the rook the queen and rook are actually
good but this rook on d8 is still
just basically a spectator
there's mike's counter play mostly all
along the c
file and sometimes against this king
but that is all the compensation that
the black has
so black really has to be careful rook
b1
hare krishna who is by the way one of
the biggest talents of india
and has been a big and important player
of india
for a long time by now he is exerting
some pressure on the b
file h6 queen d3 and i really like this
move queen d3
by hari krishna he is preparing the idea
of taking on b6
but if he would have done so earlier on
there's rook c4 hitting the queen
so if he takes then there's rook c4
immediately attacking the queen and
that's actually not that great that's
why he sort of goes queen d3 first
making sure that black cannot win time
rook c6 and
again it seems like there's nothing
going on
but hari krishna's next move is sort of
awe-inspiring
so i am going to ask you to try to find
this move
because it's sort of the key of white's
concept
so so far white has trouble breaking
through
because the black queen and rook is just
building a fortress
but of course here white has this move
of a5
and that will just break on through
yes it gives a better structure for
black
but what hare krishna is banking on
is a strong piece play along the seventh
rank
with that rook between c8 green f3
now again if you consult the computer
the computer
will scoff at this and say this is not
enough
but just by a sample line of rook c7
losing on the spot
you'll understand that defending is not
so easy
because if you take it's checkmate on g7
so even though white's pieces look a bit
scattered
and he spawns weak but he does get a lot
of play
along the f file and the seventh
rook f8 rook b8 so this rook is badly
untouchable
because if you touch it then there's
queen take c6
rupee 8 queen d7 rook
1b7 and this is kind of
the hare krishna kind of way of playing
he goes for activity
and hopes to use it to the max
rook c7 takes takes
rook b8 and goes king e7
and in the upcoming moves what will be
very interesting
how both sides are going to be staunchly
refusing
any chances for a draw so rook g8
queen c6 e4 not interested in an end
game
he wants to attack because with these
heavy pieces
and the king's still in the middle he
believes he gets good and attacking
chances and that is actually correct
it is still very much of a balanced
position
g6 a solid move
but again for us to understand how to
play this
um we've got to realize
that this king on e7 is just bad i said
that earlier on
i just wanted to sort of reconfirm that
queen e3 so our christian immediately
goes after the h
pawn and if you could take it he will
get behind
and outflanking that king with dangerous
threats
g5 h4 he's saying
okay if i can do those exchanges that
would be perfect
queen c5 queen f3 no exchanges
for you queen e5
takes takes rook a8
so this is what we would call a
dynamically balanced position
black has a better structure but a
significantly worse king in the middle
queen c5 queen h5 still trying to get
behind
of that side of the board rook g8
queen e5 queen g4
a4 rook takes g5 and here i think
the mistake occurred he really should
have taken this pawn on c3
and should have enough to hold but
for some reason or another he might have
felt
that this a pawn can make a run for it
and if you have a c c3 and c4 pawns
there
you'll never be able to go back with
your queen
via queen g7 and queen a1 or at least
that's how i would try to make sense
of donchenko not actually taking c3
queen f6 so this is a very dangerous
situation for both sides
the pawn is rushing down to become
a queen but
you can stop queening happening by
checkmating
so with that any ideas how we could get
closer
to this king on e7
because right now that king on e7 is
actually chillin there's just too many
pawns
providing its shelter
but if we could sort of peel that away
white is going to be able to get some
good play against the king
well if you can't go rook h5 rook h1 but
that's more defensive in nature and what
hari krishna was doing all along
is being very very aggressive going for
the mate instead of defending
so it is just logical to follow that up
in the same
direction and same vein
so here in this position her krishna
played c5
he didn't play e5 because these pawns
are actually useless they're not really
helping with the attack
unlike this e pawn because after c5
once they take there'll be this extra
option of e5
not only closing that diagonal
this diagonal for the queen but
also sort of boxing that king in
and potentially setting up some very
nice ideas
rook takes c5 a3 e5
and this might have been something that
don chenko underestimated
he saw that he's just way too close to
get a queen but it really doesn't matter
in this situation
that king is just way too exposed and
just not
enough interaction between that rook and
queen right now
to hold it together queen h8
queen b4 immediately going for that one
and rook c7 and rook chx are just
very powerful even if you go here that's
just not enough
check check and you will get mated so
you don't have the luxury of just
trying to run away with the queen so
queen a
check king h2 cool and
calm if you check again i'd assume
that white would just go king g1 and you
run out of checks
and you still have to deal with rook c7
and rook c8 so king h2
king e8 but here comes the other problem
rook b5 oh wrong one
rogue b5 rook b8 is coming there and you
just don't have enough defenders
to stop yourself from losing material
queen c6 it does help
it won't lose its queen but dunchenko
does lose the game
as after queen d4 what is going to pick
up that rook
therefore don chenko resigned so
really what we've learned from these
tata steel and games
is that the more weaknesses you get
the more targets you can find the more
likely you're going to win
also you really should be patient when
you're trying to convert
the smallest of advantages thank you so
much for watching
and have a good night
[Music]
you